oui je sais il ya déjà dix mille vidéos
sur youtube qui parle de l'alcool en
même temps maintenant tu prends
n'importe quel mot du dictionnaire
essuie glace tu le tape sur youtube tu
trouve forcément des dizaines de vidéos
sur ce sujet enzo sur le net les
essuie-glaces les podcasts de matteo les
cinq types d'essuie-glace remix dubstep
déjà je me dois de rappeler que l'alcool
est à consommer avec modération à une
règle que tout le monde respecte
évidemment faux j'ai l'impression que
qu'avant de boire at elle été un mec
normal quand tu dis que tu es du cheval
tu fais aussi double poney ou ou que
cheval et puis en buvant quelques verres
d'alcool va t remplacé par un autre toit
en toit plus désinhibé et je te remplace
huawei tas d origine haïtienne toi
comment tu sais je connais les femmes
jusqu'à un moment donné où tu arrives à
un verre qui s'appelle le verre de trop
est-ce que moi serveurs un verre de trop
te plaît un bar de trop ok un petit
verre de trop pour le monsieur merci mon
grand la particularité de ce ver c'est
que le mec style est en toi et remplacé
par un autre mec qui est une sorte de
deux grosses merdes oui moi aussi je me
suis déjà bourré la gueule dit mille
fois mais je suis désolé voir ça va
quand même un peu con je veux dire quand
tu as une idée bourré c'est rarement une
idée de génie
flash spécial exceptionnel yoann un jeu
bourré de 25 ans ivre mort renault va
mettre contre le cancer
non ça se passe rarement comme ça un mec
qui a une idée bourré c'est plutôt en
même temps je comprends que les gens
aient peur de l'alcool quand je vois les
reportages qui font à la télé alors
certes l'alcool c'est hyper dangereux
faut faire très attention et je suis le
premier à le dire mais dans ses
reportages
il arrive à faire passer des jeunes qui
passent une soirée plutôt normal pour
des [ __ ] de toxico paris xième
arrondissement
il est 23 heures romain et ses amis
semblent passer une soirée à peu près
normale pourtant sur la table que des
alcools forts
l'ambition est claire
s'alcooliser là en général qu'ils
emploient des expressions en anglais que
personne n'utilise dans le monde toute
la nuit
ces jeunes vont pratiquer le binge
drinking le speed drinking le whisky
jumping ou encore l'aquaplaning non je
suis petite soirée entre potes dont bois
pour le délire le délire c'est comme ça
que corentin minimise son acte d'alcool
défonce non mais voilà on n'abuse pas
trop on prend quelques verres juste pour
le kiff le kiff c'est bel et bien le mot
qu'il emploie pour désigner cette drogue
brad avec vos questions l'avons soulevé
soul et le mot choisi semble être un
lapsus révélateur
excusez moi sont les toilettes toilettes
c'est sans doute le lieu où ce jeune il
ira se faire vomir après sept prix une
biture express 2004 cake
c'est sans doute le mot que ce jeune
emploi ces reportages préventif c'est
vraiment une bonne initiative mais ils
prennent vraiment des pierres incroyable
les jeunes qu'ils interviewent dedans
c'est pas forcément des lumières
j'espère c'est qu'on voit pas comme des
abrutis
pourquoi on a fini notre verre on va
voir un autre
d'accord bon bah c'est ce qui s'appelle
bord comme un abruti en fait moi j'ai
déjà fait 10 milliards de soirées
alcoolisées mais j'ai jamais vu un mec
faire ça beaucoup ne savent plus ce
qu'ils font certains se mettent en
danger
lui c'est pas juste un mec bourré c'est
un mec bourré serial killer moi j'aime
pas trop boire en plus quand je vois
j'ai des mauvais réflexe bon comme le
réflexe de rappeler mon ex par exemple
on a inventé un système pour empêcher ça
à peine actuelle
moi rien que tu m'as souffler dessus je
suis un peu rêver quand tu bois l'alcool
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une sorte de
filtre qui se dépose sur tes yeux et qui
change le monde salue
ah ah je suis tombé
mais
j'ai pas arrêté de le répéter dans la
vidéo mais vraiment buvez avec
modération
c'est vraiment très sérieux le moins
possible voire pas du tout ou
éventuellement un petit panache et à
votre mariage
merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo si vous
avez aimé n'hésitez pas à mettre un
petit pouce en l'air à partager ma vidéo
à vous abonner à ma chaîne youtube à
vous faire un sandwich a très vite je
vous aime tous vraiment tous tous
on n'a pas tous si tous tous spectacles
norman sur scène actuellement à paris au
palace je sais pas pourquoi je suis
haute
c'est un délire à les revoir
je